hey guys it is the 30th of April my name
is Jess McDonald and you are watching
games but news some stuff happened and
I'm going to tell you about it first up
the ps4 controllers light bar which was
annoying everybody can now be controlled
by the system's 1.7 update within the
update not only can you dim the
DualShock 4 slight fide you can also use
the touchpad to mouse around the
on-screen keyboard ps4 owners will also
be able to disable hdcp for games
meaning you can now use external video
capture devices and also includes new
PlayStation camera voice commands and
increased live streaming resolution and
archiving support the ability to preload
pre-ordered games that are purchased
digitally and the video editing software
share factory it's also now much easier
to connect your vita to your ps4 with
readers own 3.15 updates nintendo really
really wants you to buy mario kart 8 so
much so that they're willing to give you
a free Wii U game for your trouble if
you're a wii u owner and mario kart 8
purchaser in north america you'll get to
pick from New Super Mario Brothers you
Pikmin 3 The Legend of Zelda Wind Waker
HD and we party you for our friends in
Europe there's another six games you can
pick from on top of those four including
the wonderful 101 and Sonic lost world
for the full list you can head over to
gamespot and check out our news story in
order to be eligible for the freebies
you'll need to register your copy on
club nintendo before July thirty-first
aside from all that Nintendo announced
today that you can totally destroy the
blue shell in mario kart 8 before it
hits you let me know in that comment box
which free Wii U game you would want and
now for some driveclub news 1080p em 30
frames per second is the thing you can
expect out of the ps4 racing game new
director Paul Rosinski has said that the
resolution and frame rate is in the
game's best interest they had originally
targeted 60 frames per second but
according to the dev 30 frames allowed
us to create some of the biggest tracks
you'll ever see in a racing game with
the most visually dense environments
as well as a full global illumination
system which allows us to make time of
day where shadows are cast full-on
reflections it's allowed us to push all
those various areas let me know whether
or not you're interested in driveclub
down in that commenting section or if
you prefer you can hit me up on my
personal twitter where i'm at just
mcdonald that is all the good stuff from
today but I will be back same time
tomorrow until then I hope you have a
great wednesday